le 31 mai 2011 pas de salaire malgré le
jugement du tribunal la justice n'a
aucun moyen de pression
nous accueillons notre invité du samedi
20h ce soir Evelyne Delagrange bonsoir
Evelyne vous êtes employé de sody
médical une entreprise de matériel pour
hôpitaux qui appartient à l'Oman et
raucher un groupe austro allemand très
prospère mais depuis le 1er mai vous et
les 50 autres employés de se dit médical
ne touchez plus de salaire vous vivez de
la charité publique nous verrons
pourquoi à 20h
[Musique]
Évelyne Delagrange bonsoir vous êtes né
le 14 février 1978 à Nantes père
bonnetier mère au foyer enfance ballotté
au gré des opportunités de travail de
votre père pour finir dans un petit
village à 30 km de 3 capitales de
l'industrie textile à l'époque alors à
l'école vous êtes une petite fille
modèle ça se passe bien vous travaillez
bien mais arrivé en quatrième vous
décrochez et en fait c'est pas c'est pas
l'adolescence c'est le divorce de vos
parents
c'est un ensemble de choses
et là au milieu de la terminale à
quelques mois du bac vous plaquez tout
pour vous installer avec votre petit ami
mauvais choix
là nous sommes en 1997 vous avez 19 ans
aucun diplôme vous devez bosser et ce
sera une boutique de prêt-à-porter dans
la région parisienne
deux ans plus tard vous repartez avec
votre copain vous installez dans la
région de Troyes
où vous trouvez un emploi dans une usine
de conditionnement de pommes de terre
c'est dur
heureusement vous trouvez autre chose la
filiale d'un groupe allemand lomane et
rausseur recrute c'est une boîte qui
fabrique et conditionne du matériel
médical pour les blocs opératoires
la boîte s'appelle donc se dit médical
ça vous plaît comme boulot au départ
des horaires corrects
alors le salaire c'est le SMIC 1050
euros par mois
mais vous dites on est déjà bien
chanceux d'avoir un travail tout à fait
proche de chez nous
donc non très bien
c'est en 2004 que débute les
dégradations des conditions de travail
vous apercevez que le nouveau directeur
fait sans arrêt des allers-retours avec
la Chine
et il vous dit ne vous inquiétez pas en
Chine ils vont fabriquer pour l'Autriche
et l'Allemagne vous vous continuerez à
fabriquer pour la France
ça vous met la puce à l'oreille quand
même oui parce qu'en fait vous comprenez
qu'ils utilisent les prototypes
fabriqués en France qui sont donc
d'excellentes qualités effectivement
pour gagner des marchés et une fois
qu'ils ont gagné les marchés ils font
fabriquer le gros de la production en
Chine on nous a demandé de fabriquer ces
prototypes justement
au bout de quelques mois la Direction
annonce
sodimical n'est pas assez concurrentiel
on vous demande des sacrifices des
efforts pour sauver la boîte on a eu de
moins en moins de travail donc on a
passé on est passé du travail en équipe
en journée
et oui on a vu les conditions se
dégradées sérieusement on vous demande
d'augmenter les cadences c'est en
échange de quoi on vous donne une prime
de productivité c'est à dire que c'est
même plus un troisième mot c'est une
prime bonus
qui est basée sur la productivité la
qualité l'absentéisme
donc dès que vous vous ratez un jour
parce que vous êtes malade
votre prime étant butée
donc voilà on n'a pas spécialement
troisièmement en fait ce qui se passe
dans cette boîte c'est que les commandes
dépendent de la maison mère lhomane et
rausseur et que c'est la maison mère qui
décide ou non de donner du travail à se
dit médical
alors en 2007 il y a une première vague
de licenciement puis une deuxième en
2009 voilà ce qu'ils font c'est quand il
est sensit il est sensit les gens par
groupe de 9 parce que à 10 il faut un
plan social c'est ça
vous dites chacun se replie sur soi-même
en priant d'être épargné
on n'était pas l'abri d'être sur la
liste puisque il y avait plusieurs
critères qui étaient pris en compte
donc tant qu'on n'a pas la liste sous
les yeux oui on se demande si on va pas
être dedans
donc est-ce que les gens sont solidaires
dans ces cas-là ou est-ce que ça vient
du chacun pour soi
je dirais qu'à cette époque c'était un
peu du chacun pour soi
alors pour ne rien arranger chez vous
c'est la crise
vous finissez par vous séparer de votre
compagnon
je me suis retrouvé toute seule avec ma
fille donc c'est difficile à gérer
le 27 avril 2011 lors d'un comité
d'entreprise le gérant de la société
présente un diaporama dont la dernière
slide annonce la fermeture de sody
médical de moi plus tard
oui c'est un peu le choc on avait
toujours espoir que le travail
reviendrait et qu'on s'en sortirait quoi
vous avez plus rien
on se demande comment on va s'en sortir
c'est ce qui va se passer après c'est un
retour à la case départ
et là commence un incroyable feuilleton
judiciaire en effet les caisses de la
maison mère lhomane et rausseur sont
pleines c'est une société extrêmement
prospère et la société sodimicale en
France donc enregistre des pertes
puisque Loman est rochers ne passe plus
de commandes à ce 10 médical donc ils
sont en train de fermer le robinet ce
qui fait que la boîte française ben
petit à petit elle coule évidemment ce
qui leur permet de dire voyez bien on va
fermer la boîte on met la liquider quoi
aucune autonomie financière
on ne pouvait pas démarcher nous-mêmes
pour essayer de trouver d'autres
il y a pas une direction française qui
pourrait chercher du boulot en France et
eux qui décident
de la maison mère voilà c'est ça le
problème et donc ils assèchent la boîte
française et vous vous retrouvez
effectivement sans boulot alors à partir
de là c'est coup pour coup les salariés
obtiennent la suspension du plan social
en échange de quoi la maison mère le
Mane et rochers demande la liquidation
de la société et ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que dans ce cas là ça coûte rien à
la boîte c'est l'état français c'est les
contribués à français qui payent
la société lomanée recherche ne vous
donne même plus de matière première pour
travailler à partir de ce moment-là
les salariés ont même peur de voir
l'usine démontée dans leur dos comme ça
comme ça arrive souvent on vous
commencez à faire des tours de garde en
vous disant ils vont tout démonter
pendant une nuit on va arriver le matin
il y aura plus de il y aura plus de
machines outils on a créé des groupes
justement pour faire de la surveillance
en permanence
le 31 mai 2011 pas de salaire malgré le
jugement du tribunal la justice n'a
aucun moyen de pression
surprenant
c'est pas l'habitude
on touchera un tiers de notre salaire de
même et mi-juin et depuis on nous verse
plus plus rien du tout
ils arrêtent de vous payer quoi comme ça
c'est ça alors la justice n'a aucun
moyen de pression puisque les caisses de
sodimical sont vides évidemment donc on
peut pas les obliger à vous payer et les
Allemands disent ben nous on y est pour
rien parce que toute façon c'est une
boîte qui est en France
il faut savoir que depuis le mois de
novembre ce 10 médical était en
cessation de paiement mais ils nous ont
quand même versé le salaire jusqu'au
mois d'avril
donc on s'est demandé après quand les
salaires ne tombaient pas qui payaient
avant
et quand vous leur dites pourquoi vous
nous payez plus qu'est-ce qui vous
disent nous nous a rien dit
personnellement en tant au niveau des
employés on nous a rien dit le 28 juin
2011 les salariés décident de séquestrer
le patron
pacifiquement
vous lui donnez un lit de camp vous le
nourrissez et vous avez même fait une
partie de cartes avec lui
mais le lendemain matin il y a 50
gendarmes armés jusqu'aux dents qui
débarque sur le site pour faire sortir
30 ouvrières
on a fait ça parce qu'on voulait nos
salaires et qu'on avait pas d'autres
moyens de pression
pour se manifester désormais à partir de
là lorsque vous et vos collègues vous
déplacez pour aller au tribunal vous
êtes encadré par les forces de l'ordre
comme des criminels
force de l'ordre
voilà alors à partir de là évidemment
c'est bien extrêmement compliqué parce
que c'est comment survivre sans salaire
la situation devient infernale vous
réduisez les dépenses quand vous allez
au supermarché vous faites très
attention à ce que vous achetez vous
achetez des produits les moins chers il
faut trouver de l'argent voilà vous
demander à tout le monde en fait est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dépanner quoi au
départ on vit sur quand même sur les
économies qu'on a après c'est un peu
difficile de réclamer parce que ça c'est
mignon comme situation
au niveau de la population
c'est sûr que sans même on aurait ça
sera peut-être pas sorti quoi après on
tape au niveau de toutes les actions
sociales qui existent pour essayer
d'avoir le plus d'argent possible et
puis les banques dans ces cas-là vous
font des crédits rivolving à 20 % donc
vous vous dites je vais mettre des
années à rembourser cet argent parce que
c'est un taux d'usure 20% quand même
c'est clair que il y aura un impact sur
plusieurs années
tout le monde nous a aidé il y a même un
type qui a traversé tout le département
mobylette pour vous donner un paquet de
biscottes c'est énorme oui c'était
génial dans ces cas-là les gens sont
formidables
[Musique]
où on peut remercier les gens même le
Labé de la commune nous a donné une
partie de sa quête
alors votre fille Sarah souffre
énormément de cette situation évidemment
parce qu'elle se rend compte il y a plus
de bonbons bon on mange plus les mêmes
yaourts à la maison enfin c'est c'est la
crise
elle réclame je peux pas lui donner
comment expliquer à votre fille que
votre patron refuse de vous payer c'est
difficile d'expliquer ça un enfant je
lui dis avec des mots d'enfants il y a
un méchant monsieur qui veut pas nous
payer quand elle le voit à la télé
d'ailleurs elle dit c'est le méchant
monsieur vas-y il se reconnaîtra mais
alors le 8 juillet 2011 François Baroin
maire de Troyes et ministre de
l'Économie décide de s'occuper de se dit
médical mais même lui tout-puissant
qu'il soit et tout ministre de
l'Économie qu'il soit il arrive pas
des promesses qui nous a fait sur les
salaires
on se sent vraiment abandonné quoi il y
a personne autour qui nous soutient quoi
la seule bonne nouvelle c'est mercredi
dernier le tribunal a reconnu que les
employés de sodimical étaient causariés
de l'Oman et rauchère la maison mère
donc même si les caisses de se dit
médical sont vides c'est donc la maison
mère qui doit payer le problème c'est
qu'entre la décision du tribunal et
l'application vous l'avez vu dans le
passé ça il se passe un temps infini
on a gagné beaucoup de procès et à
chaque fois
le lendemain on nous annonce autre chose
et on est content et le lendemain tout
disparaît quoi et on passe notre temps à
refaire les procédures qui sont sortis
on s'aperçoit que l'État c'est à dire la
justice française les tribunaux prennent
des décisions et qu'elles ne sont pas
mises en application et que vous restez
dans votre situation
alors ce qu'il faut dire aussi c'est que
nous donc la rédaction de cette émission
on a tenté de joindre par courrier par
téléphone la direction de l'Oman et
resserre et qu'à ce jour c'est un peu
comme vous nous n'avons reçu aucune
réponse voilà mais on s'arrêtera pas là
on est prêt à continuer à se battre
longtemps
vous avez raison
merci en tous les cas de votre
témoignage
on vous souhaite que le meilleur courage
merci beaucoup
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu